ja und hier hat die aktuelle Stunde
gerade begonnen wie angekündigt von der
cdu/csu-fraktion hier in den Deutschen
Bundestag beantragt und wir hören gleich
rein was der erste Redner sagt Jens
Spahn noch nicht deswegen Service
Opposition werden wir diese 101 Fragen
als kleine Anfrage einreichen damit Sie
auch tatsächlich eine Antwort zurück
die Grünen schlagen zurück die
Fraktionsvorsitzende der Grünen wirft
der
fdp-arbeitsverweigerung vor Kollege von
Notz nennt die FDP verantwortungslos die
FDP ist eine unzuverlässige und
destruktive clicke Lindner ist ein König
ohne Land so der Kollege Marcel Emmerich
man könnte stundenlang so weitermachen
Material gibt es genug allein aus den
letzten zwei drei Tagen nur wie geht's
den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern dabei
rekordinflation
Durchschnittsverdiener haben vier 500
Euro netto im Monat weniger zu Verfügung
viele wissen nicht wie sie über die
Runden kommen sollen und dann ziehen Sie
hier seit Tagen so ein Schauspiel hat
sie maximieren Verunsicherung Frust und
Wut durch die Art und Weise wie sie
miteinander umgehen
sie sorgen sich um Zeitpläne und
Formalien streiten auf Twitter nur um
die existenziellen Ängste der Leute im
echten im realen Leben um die kümmert
sich gerade keiner liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der Ampel das ist macht
vergessen das ist selbstbezogen das ist
unwürdig beenden Sie diese Schauspiel
ziehen Sie den Gesetzentwurf zurück
gehen Sie zurück auf Los und fangen sie
im Sinne der Sache des Klimaschutzes
noch mal ganz von vorne
und zwar mit einem Gebäude Energiegesetz
das Fristen hat die Planbarkeit und
Verlässlichkeit schaffen statt
Überforderung wirklich technologieoffen
und ohne diese Fixierung nur auf die
Wärmepumpe und mit der Förderung die
sicherstellt dass niemand überfordert
wird aber eigentlich liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen geht es um grundsätzlicher
es geht um den Zustand dieser Regierung
und darum was das mit dem Land macht die
nationale Sicherheitsstrategie würde
kurzfristig als Tagesordnungspunkt für
den morgigen Vormittag abgesetzt Krieg
in Europa und diese Regierung hat keine
Sicherheitsstrategie die china-strategie
wird verschoben und vertagt der Haushalt
2024 lässt auf sich warten der Streit um
die Grundsicherung geht seit Monaten
planungsbeschleunigung bei der
Infrastruktur wird verzögert der
Wirtschaftsminister kündigt vorgestern
in einer Pressekonferenz ein
industriestrompreis an der
Finanzminister sagt gestern in
öffentlichen da rede ausdrücklich das
wird so niemals kommen liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen das ist ja sie klatschen
aber treten sie mal einen Schritt zurück
Deutschland ist die viertgrößte
Volkswirtschaft der Welt das was der
Wirtschafts-
wie dieser Standort gesichert werden
kann und wir erleben seit Tagen nicht
nur in dieser einen Frage sondern in
allen politischen Fragen dass sie sich
nicht einigen können und das ist
mittlerweile eine standortgefahr für die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland
Stress
Stress Selbstbeschäftigung Chaos
Blockade auf dem Weg in die
Regierungsunfähigkeit das ist der
Zustand der Koalition Krieg in Europa
rekordinflation
migrationskrise ein Land auf dem Weg in
die stadtflation und kollektiv schlechte
Stimmung das sind die Themen der Bürger
und er fragt man sich übrigens auch
heute wo ist eigentlich der Kanzler
politische Führung ist mehr gefragt denn
je aber vom Kanzler gibt es bestenfalls
durchhaltephrasen aller you never walk
alone ansonsten Fehlanzeige und deswegen
bleiben statt 101 Fragen eigentlich nur
zwei Fragen übrig hat dieser Kanzler hat
diese Regierung noch die Kraft die
Führung den Willen in diesen multiplen
Krisen das zu tun was nötig ist um
Deutschland und die deutschen gut durch
diese Zeit zu führen
und die zweite Frage liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen ist hat der Kanzler hat der
Vizekanzler hat der Finanzminister hat
diese Regierung haben die eigentlich für
das was sie tun noch die das Vertrauen
der Mehrheit dieses Parlament ist diese
Frage stellt sich mittlerweile
angesichts dessen was sie in den letzten
Tagen die aufhören
Kollege
in Zeiten in Zeiten der Krise braucht es
politische Führung und Verlässlichkeit
die liefern sie nicht auch in dieser
Woche wieder nicht besinnen sie sich im
Interesse unseres Landes
Jens Spahn hier in der Aktuellen Stunde
die die cdu/csu-fraktion beantragt hat
weil eben es Probleme in der großen in
der Ampelkoalition gibt die Reform des
Gebäude Energiegesetzes wird nun wohl
nicht vor der Sommerpause verabschiedet
weil die FDP-Fraktion grundsätzliche
Bedenken hat das führt zu Verstimmungen
weil
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Robert habe
ich eben mit einer schnellen
Verabschiedung gerechnet hat er wirkte
FDP auch Wort brauchen vor und auch die
SPD fordert eine schnelle Verabschiedung
des Gesetzes für die SPD Matthias Mersch
also sie haben von Schauspiel gesprochen
was sie jetzt hier abgezogen haben
gleich ein Schauspiel und einen übel
faustspiel im übrigen auch denn wenn Sie
hier Führungslosigkeit Mann wer hat denn
die Versorgungssicherheit mit Energie im
letzten Jahr gesichert wer hat die
Bezahlbarkeit in diesem Land von Energie
gesichert es war die Ampel sie haben
Vorschläge gemacht die genau in die
andere Richtung gegangen sind
und dann würde ich mir noch mal
vorstellen dass sie wenigstens eine
Aktuelle Stunde machen und wir in
irgendeiner Form von ihnen in der Sache
mal was hören wo sind denn bitte die
Vorschläge hier das Thema Wärme von der
CDU zu beantworten liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
wo ist ein Vorschlag stattdessen eine
üble populistische Kampagne wo sie den
Menschen etwas vormachen und übelst
übelst mit den Ängsten spielen lieber
Herr Spahn
ich sage Ihnen ja sie haben Recht Herr
Merz hören sie zu hören Sie einfach mal
zu die Herr Spahn hat in einem Herr
Spahn hat in einem Punkt recht es geht
um sehr sehr grundsätzliche Fragen denn
wir haben denn wir haben zusammen
mittlerweile sind sie ja sogar Fan des
Gesetzes habe ich gehört wir haben
gemeinsam ein Klimaschutzgesetz hier
beschlossen dieses Klimaschutzgesetz
sieht vor dass wir im Jahre 2045
klimaneutral sind bis dato kann es keine
fossilen Heizsysteme mehr gehen wir
haben parallel dazu ein CO2-Preis
beschlossen sie plädieren für den
Emissionshandel das klingt im Moment
alles super wohin führt es wenn wir
jetzt nicht handeln und sensibilisieren
und den Menschen sagen dass sie
umsteigen müssen das führt dazu dass wir
spätestens 2028/29
Preise erleben wo die Leute plötzlich
wenn sie alleine auf das fossile Energie
setzen entweder nicht mehr heizen können
oder sie Anlagen auswechseln müssen aber
dann ganz plötzlich und das ist der
Schock den wir genau nicht wollen das
ist unser grundsätzlicher Unterschied
und deswegen wenn Sie hier sagen
Klimaschutz ohne Kostenschock sie
provozieren dass viele viele Millionen
von Haushalte irgendwann den Schock
haben das muss man den Leuten sagen wenn
es hier um diese Debatten geht
und dann flankieren sie das alles noch
und sagen und sagen beispielsweise
verheizt nicht meine Miete wer war in
dem letzten in der letzten
Legislaturperiode mit uns nicht in der
Lage die Mieterinnen und Mieter in
angemessen zu schützen vor einem hohen
CO2-Preis und eine Aufteilung
hinzubekommen das waren sie
und eine besondere Stilblüte Herr
Kollege Merz ist dann noch die Aussage
verheizt nicht unsere Rente da sagen sie
mit 66 Jahren da fängt das Leben an ich
hoffe der Flugblatt wird jetzt ganz
schnell geändert denn ich habe ja
gestern genommen die CDU will jetzt die
Rente mit 72 also fangen sie an das ist
das ist CDU
aber in der Tat ist ja nicht zu spät und
eine Aktuelle Stunde kann ja auch anders
sein wir werden hier im Parlament die
Vorlage der Regierung in der Tat beraten
und jeder und jeder Vorschlag von ihnen
ist willkommen jeder Vorschlag von ihnen
ist Willkommen Wir haben im letzten Jahr
richtig viel geschafft im Bereich
erneuerbarer Energien und wir werden in
diesen in diesen in dieser in diesem
beratungsablauf den nächsten großen
Punkt das Heizen und vornehmen und wir
werden beweisen müssen und das ist nicht
einfach aber wir werden beweisen müssen
das Klimaschutz und sozialer
Zusammenhalt tatsächlich organisierbar
sind insofern werden wir über Förderung
reden
wir werden über die Frage von
Technologien reden wir werden die Frage
von Übergangsfristen etc behandeln ich
bin mir sehr sicher wir werden in dieser
Ampel jetzt auch dieses große Thema
angehen was wir leider mit Ihnen
zusammen nicht angehen konnten wir
werden das Thema Heizung und im übrigen
auch das Thema Mobilität angehen meine
Bitte an Sie ist dass Sie nicht den
Populismus nachgehen weil ansonsten
machen Sie eine Truppe stark und die
sitzt dort vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
soweit dir wiederum von Matthias Miersch
zuletzt hatte hier dann auch noch mal
auf die AFD verwiesen und die kann nun
hier als nächstes reden mag Bernhard ist
der baupolitische Sprecher der
afd-fraktion hat sich auch schon klar
gegen das neue heizungsgesetz
ausgesprochen
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
wir haben uns bei der Energiewende
geirrt
werden das schon bereits vor zehn Jahren
gesagt
kein klimaleugner kein
Verschwörungstheoretiker und auch kein
afd-politiker nein es war habecks
entlassener Staatssekretär reichen denn
der letzte Woche als denjenigen der die
Energiewende wieder zum Laufen gebracht
habe verabschiedet hat reichen vor zehn
Jahren zu wörtlich wir haben uns geirrt
bei der Energiewende nicht in ein paar
Details sondern in einem zentralen Punkt
die vielen Windräder und Solaranlagen
die Deutschland baut leisten nicht das
was wir uns von ihnen versprochen haben
wir hatten gehofft dass sie die
schmutzigen Kohlekraftwerke ersetzen
werden durch das tun sie eben nicht wenn
reichen also schon vor zehn Jahren
wusste dass die Energiewende nicht
funktioniert warum wird sie dann jetzt
mit aller Macht durchgedrückt warum
werden per Notverordnung landschafts-
obwohl er also genau wusste dass die
Energiewende überhaupt nicht
funktioniert wollte er in ihrem Auftrag
haben mit dem heizungshammer mehr als 60
Millionen Menschen dazu zwingen
zukünftig nur noch mit Strom zu heizen
dabei wusste doch ganz genau dass dafür
aufgrund der Abschaltung der kern- und
Kohlekraftwerke gar nicht genügend Strom
zur Verfügung steht so kann
beispielsweise Deutschlands größte
Wohnungsgesellschaft unzählige
elektrische Wärmepumpen nicht im Betrieb
nehmen weil der Strom fehlt trotzdem
hatte den Gesetzentwurf ganz bewusst so
geschrieben dass wir die meisten
Menschen nur noch der Einbau einer
Wärmepumpe möglich ist und das obwohl
das Heizen mit Strom auch noch um 30%
teurer als mit Gas ist gut dass so
jemand weg ist
und jetzt jetzt muss auch dieser
heizungshammer Weg und zwar komplett weg
denn ist doch völlig absurd das den
Menschen verboten werden soll mit Gas zu
heizen während die Regierung
gleichzeitig 50
Gaskraftwerke bauen will wo man dann mit
dreckigem fracking-gas den Strom erzeugt
Zeugen will mit dem die Menschen
zukünftig heizen sollen was für ein
Aberwitz und als ich Ihnen als ich ihn
im April vorgerechnet habe dass dieser
heizungshammer die Menschen
2000 Milliarden Euro kosten würde haben
sie mich hier im Deutschen Bundestag
ungläubig angeschaut und mit dem Kopf
geschüttet und jetzt und jetzt haben
ganz offensichtlich sie ja selbst von
der FDP mal nachgerechnet und kommen
sogar auf 200 Milliarden Euro also
30.000 € pro Kopf der Bevölkerung
und Wissenschaftler bestätigen dass es
damit noch nicht einmal seine
CO2-Einsparung kommt ja der Schwachsinn
wurde doch von ihrer von ihren
fdp-kollegen bestätigt die haben doch
nachgerechnet 2500 Milliarden Euro
die Welt und eins ist doch klar die
wärmewende ist nicht machbar denn wir
haben nicht genügend Wärmepumpen wir
haben nicht genügend Handwerker wir
haben nicht genügend Strom und die
Menschen haben schon gar nicht genügend
Geld um diesen Wahnsinn zu bezahlen und
jetzt und jetzt kommen sie von der CDU
und spielen sich hier als Retter der
Nation auf und wollen die Wärme werden
die angeblich
sozialverträglich neu starten was sie
unter sozial versteht haben sie uns ja
mit ihrem Antrag in der letzten
Sitzungswoche klar und deutlich gezeigt
sie setzen darauf dass die Brüsseler
CO2-Zertifikate Öl und Gas so teuer
machen dass sich die Menschen Öl und Gas
praktisch gar nicht mehr leisten können
ab 2027 gehen Experten davon aus dass es
zu einer Verzehnfachung des co2-preises
auf bis zu 300 Euro pro Tonne kommen
wird wenn ein Liter Diesel bedeutet es
eine Preiserhöhung umfasst einen Euro
das verstehen sie von der CDU also unser
sozialverträglich
das einzige das einzige was wirklich
sozialverträglich ist und die Menschen
vor Altersarmut und faktischer
Enteignung schützt ist diese ganze
wärmewende auf dem Misthaufen der
Geschichte zu entsorgen
Marc Bernhard aus der afd-fraktion hat
sich hier gegen die Pläne von
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck
ausgesprochen Robert Habeck war auch
schon länger hier im Plenum saß da
allerdings erst einmal in den Reihen
seiner Fraktion und für die Grünen
Fraktion spricht nun der
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzender
Andreas audritsch
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren
die Debatten der vergangenen Tage und
auch Wochen sind hart geführt worden und
es gibt Momente der sollte man auch im
politischen Alltag auf grundsätzliches
zu bekommen das erste ist eine
Vereinbarung in der Politik aber auch
ehrlich gesagt eine Vereinbarung die man
unter Menschen trifft sollte etwas wert
sein
wir haben das Gebäude Energiegesetz in
Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart im
Koalitionsausschuss wurde das Gesetz am
24 März 2022 unter der Leitung des
Bundeskanzlers und unter Beteiligung von
Ministerinnen Ministern
parteichefsfraktionschefs aller
ampelparteien bestätigt auch von
Christian Lindner auch von Christian
Dörr am 28 März 2023 wurde ebenfalls
unter der Leitung des Bundeskanzlers und
und unter Beteiligung aller beschlossen
das Gesetz wird von der Bundesregierung
im April im Kabinett auf den Weg
gebracht um es vor der Sommerpause im
Bundestag zu beschließen am 19 April
2023 hat das Bundeskabinett den
Gesetzentwurf verabschiedet und ja es
gab an der Stelle eine Protokolle
Erklärung aber auch in der
Protokollerklärung steht sehr sehr klar
die Fraktionen des Deutschen Bundestages
im Parlament werden im parlamentarischen
Verfahren diesen Gesetzentwurf intensiv
beraten und auch weitere notwendige
Änderungen vornehmen Zitat Ende genau
darum geht es wir sind ein Parlament mit
selbstbewussten Parlamentariern und
ParlamentarierInnen das Gesetz muss
beraten werden muss hier beraten werden
das ist das da wo es hingehört das ist
Aufgabe von uns parlamentarien lassen
Sie uns die Blockade an der Stelle
auflösen genau diese Beratungen müssen
jetzt beginnen
und selbstverständlich haben da alle
möglichen unterschiedliche Positionen
und Sichtweisen lassen Sie uns darüber
reden lassen Sie uns über Fristen reden
lassen Sie uns über Ausnahmen reden
lassen Sie uns darüber reden wie man
technologieoffenheit dia Grundlage
dieses Gesetzes ist noch deutlicher
heraus arbeitet wenn das nötig ist
lassen Sie uns darüber reden aber lassen
Sie uns den Job machen den wir hier im
Parlament haben und genau das Anschauen
das ist das was jetzt ansteht und was
wir tun sollten und ich sage Ihnen gerne
ich sage Ihnen gerne um einen Schritt
inhaltlicher zu machen das was sie nie
tun Liebe Union das was wir für richtig
erachten das was jetzt passieren sollten
wir wollen dass Menschen vor allem mit
kleinen Einkommen Sicherheit bekommen
und auch Unterstützung bekommen wir
wollen als grüne Bundestagsfraktion dass
die mit wenig Einkommen 80% der
Investitionen refinanziert kriegen sie
haben sie haben nicht einen Satz dazu
sie haben noch nicht mal eine Idee dazu
es gibt nichts von ihnen kein Konzept
gar nichts und sie bleiben auf während
sie sich nicht darum scheren was
Menschen tatsächlich in diesem Land
brauchen
und gleichzeitig gilt Sicherheit und
Verlässlichkeit auch für Handwerker auch
für Heizungsbauer auch für Unternehmer
alle die da draußen sind die eigentlich
wissen wollen wie sie mitarbeiten können
an der Zukunft die
Milliardeninvestitionen auf den Weg
gebracht haben oder davor stehen sich zu
entscheiden von mir aus kriegt man da im
Detail unterschiedliche Antworten aber
es gibt eine Antwort die immer sehr sehr
klar sind wir brauchen Klarheit wir
brauchen die Verantwortung der
Abgeordneten jetzt deutlich zu machen wo
es hingeht weil sie investieren wollen
weil wir Zukunftstechnologien hochlaufen
lassen wollen weil wir sehen dass wir
ein verdammter Konkurrenz stehen mit
asiatischen Herstellern mit chinesischen
Hersteller mit amerikanischen
Herstellern und wir dieser
zukunftsindustrie eine Zukunft in
Deutschland geben müssen wir können uns
nicht leisten länger am Flughafen
festhalten das ist das was jetzt ansteht
und was wir gemeinsam machen müssen
und an der Stelle noch einmal zurück zu
Ihnen zur Union sie dürfen sie dürfen
dagegen sein das ist ihr Job als Union
geschenkt machen sie das aber ich habe
mal geguckt auf Ihre Homepage auf den
Kampagnen Homepage das wo sie viel Geld
für ausgeben ich habe in ihren Flyern
nachgeguckt die Suppe ist so dünn sie
könnte nicht dünner sein keine
Vorschläge nicht zum Thema soziale
Ausgleich und dann sagen sie in meinem
Halbsatz ja CO2-Preis es gibt keine
einzige Antwort was das bedeutet es gibt
keine Antwort wie hoch der Preis wäre es
gibt keine Antwort wir teuer dann Heizöl
wäre es gibt keine Antwort darauf wie
teuer dann Gas wird sagen sie einmal was
Sache sagen sie einmal was die Menschen
zumuten würden wenn sie das machen was
sie vorschlagen wir wollen einmal sehen
wo es hingehen wir wollen einmal einen
Konzept sind von der Union und nicht
immer nur populistische Kampagne ich
sage Ihnen was
Opposition entlarvt sich selber wenn es
offensichtlich nur noch darum geht mit
billiger Polemik Stimmung zu machen
ihnen ist völlig egal dass sie keinerlei
Rezepte haben weil sie Gefangene sind
eines alten fossilen Denkens einer alten
fossilen Lobby mit einem einzigen Ziel
den Weg ins erneuerbare Zeitalter zu
blockieren das ist das Einzige was die
vorhaben und das wird es nicht mehr
geben das kann es nicht mehr geben und
deswegen werden sie mit dieser Haltung
untergehen ich kann Ihnen versichern wir
gehen diesen Weg voran wir werden Ihre
alten fossilen Ideen beenden und wir
werden aufbrechen in ein zukünftiges
erneuerbares Zeitalter mit Wohlstand für
alle in Deutschland
wie die Menschen unterstützt werden
können wenn denn nun neue Gasheizungen
oder neue Heizungen eingebaut werden
können waren natürlich auch eine der
großen Fragen der Linksfraktion für die
Linke sprechenden
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das Desaster
und das heizungsgesetz macht das Ganze
Unvermögen dieser Bundesregierung
sichtbar sie haben ihren Laden wirklich
nicht im Griff
man einfach mal in den Rücken von
Minister Habeck die Pläne für sein
Gesetzesvorhaben an die Presse raus und
seitdem streiten sie sich hier auf
offener Bühne und das bei einem Vorhaben
das einschneidende Konsequenzen haben
wird für das Leben von praktisch jedem
Menschen in unserem Land ja wir brauchen
die wärmewende aber nicht auf dem Rücken
der Bürgerinnen und Bürger nicht auf dem
Rücken der Klang Kommunen die jetzt
schon nicht mehr einen noch aus wissen
und vor allem brauchen wir realistische
Ziele Ziele die sozialverantwortbar sind
und kein grünes wünscht dir was aus der
wohlfühl Blase sie sollten dieses
vermochte gesetzt komplett zurückziehen
und erstmal ihre Haus Aufgaben machen so
sieht's aus wie kann es sein
dass diese Bundesregierung schon wieder
einfach ein einschneidendes
Gesetzesvorhaben raushaut und sich erst
im Nachgang und erst nach massivem
Widerstand der Bevölkerung überhaupt mal
Gedanken darüber macht welche Folgen
diese Pläne für unser Land haben die
kann das sein ich mein bauministerin
geil wird und ihre Partei der SPD der
fällt allen Ernstes erst jetzt auf dass
die Mehrkosten für die teureren
Wärmepumpen und die notwendigen Umbauten
in Mehrfamilienhäuser dass das auf die
Mieterinnen und Mieter abgewälzt werden
wird dass dadurch die Mieten massiv
steigen der guten Morgen wenn sie noch
gleich auffallen müssen Sie doch gleich
verhindern sollen zum Beispiel indem man
endlich die Modernisierungsumlage
abschafft nein stattdessen da werden sie
auch hier nur wieder herum es ist
einfach beschenkt der deutsche Städte
und Gemeindebund spricht von 8
Milliarden Euro Zusatzkosten für die
Kommunen wer soll das bezahlen wie
stellen Sie sicher dass Ihre wärmewende
nicht auf Kosten der Schulgebäude der
öffentlichen Bibliotheken oder
Schwimmbäder geht sie müssen die
Kommunen mitnehmen und nicht in den Ruin
treiben Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und wie stellen Sie sicher dass Menschen
nicht ihre Häuser verlieren weil sich
die Mehrkosten nicht leisten können ihre
halbgaren Förderpläne reichen da bei
weitem nicht aus selbst wenn man alle
bislangen redestehenden Förderungen
klimaboni gegenrechnet bleibt eine
Familie mit einem durchschnittlichen
Haushaltseinkommen auf Mehrkosten von 5
bis 20.000 Euro sitzen für den Einbau
einer Wärmepumpe im Vergleich zur
Gasheizung und die eventuell erheblichen
Umbaukosten der Häuser sind noch nicht
mal eingerechnet und ja da rufen die
Grünen schon dazwischen moment mal da
wollen wir doch nachbessern bei den
Familien mit einem Jahreseinkommen von
bis zu 20.000 € sollen wir doch 80% der
Einbaukosten übernehmen
ich meine diejenigen die bei einem
solchen Einkommen überhaupt ein
Eigenheim haben den reichen die 80% doch
nicht aus die sollen die Leute die
Umbaukosten bezahlen ist einfach
unverantwortlich was sie hier
vorschlagen
und die ersten negativen Folgen ihrer
Pläne die kann man jetzt schon bestaunen
die Preise für Wärmepumpen die gehen in
die Höhe weil nicht genug Wärmepumpen
und da sind und so ein Vorhaben war
umsetzen zu können in der von Ihnen
vorgesehenen frisst ganz zu schweigen
von den fehlenden Handwerkern wo ist da
eigentlich realitative für mehr
Fachkräfte die jetzt ausgebildet werden
müssen
außerdem werden zurzeit so viele
Gasheizungen eingebaut die wohl noch nie
weil sie die sich leisten können noch
schnell neues Gerät anschaffen weil sie
in den nächsten Jahren nicht mit
unkalkulierbaren Mehrkosten belastet
werden wollen fakt ist sie beschleunigen
nicht die wärmewende sie beschleunigen
Politikverdrossenheit und das ist hoch
gefährlich unsere Demokratie mit diesem
Wort spielen Sie den rechten Klima und
Leuten direkt in die Hände und damit
meine ich übrigens die alle miteinander
auch die FDP die sich plötzlich als
Retterin des kleinen Mannes inszeniert
nur um sich öffentlich gegen ihren
Koalitionspartner besser inszenieren zu
können wie unseriös geht es eigentlich
und ja dann ist er noch die SPD die ein
Kanzler einfach alles laufen lässt
zwischendurch mal lapidar behaupte man
habe einfach alles im Griff alone das
glaubt ihn wirklich keine mehr
und dann sind noch die Grünen den
blinder Mission jede Kritik an
Arbeitsplänen als majestiz Beleidigung
hinstellen und moralisch aufgeladene
Abwehr Debatten führen wer sie
kritisiert ist angeblich ich
fortschrittlich dem ist die Zukunft des
Planeten das Leben unserer Kinder egal
und und und fast 80% der Menschen in
Deutschland lehnen ihr Gesetzesvorhaben
ab
diese Menschen sind doch nicht alle
rückwärtsgewandt oder klimaleugner und
die sind auch nicht alle irgendeiner
Kampagne aufgesessen machen sie mal die
Augen auf nehmen Sie die Sorgen ernst
und machen Sie Ihre Arbeit ziehen Sie
das Gesetz zurück und legen Sie uns hier
einen abgestimmten realistischen und
sozial ausgewogenen Plan vor und jetzt
noch ein letztes Wort zur Union die er
heute diese aktuelle Stunde einberufen
hat nichts für Unmut Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die wärmewende und der soziale
Ausgleich hat sie in all den vielen
Jahren in den sie regiert haben
überhaupt nicht interessiert und ich
meine sie haben dieses Thema jetzt nicht
entdeckt weil Ihre Meinung geändert
haben sondern weil zum Schluss
profilieren können das leider die
Wahrheit danke schön
in der Koalition gibt es besonders
Streit zwischen FDP und Grüne die grüne
die Grünen haben eine FDP geworden
vorgeworfen die FDP möchte mehr
Informationen haben über den
Gesetzentwurf für die FDP-Fraktion
spricht nun Lukas Köhler und der
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzender
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
lieber Kollege Spahn ich freue mich hab
was gelernt ist nicht gut ich habe
gelernt ich habe gelernt dass die Union
eigentlich ziemlich froh ist in der
Opposition zu sein die Union freut sich
darüber die Antwort auf diese Debatte
nicht geben zu müssen weil warum Ringen
wir so denn darum wie das mit den
Heizungen in Deutschland weitergeht weil
es notwendig ist eine Antwort auf die
Frage zu geben was will ich was muss ich
als Bürger als Bürgerin tun um für den
Klimaschutz vorbereitet zu sein was muss
ich tun weil die CO2-Preise steigen
werden was muss ich tun damit ich mehr
Heizung in Zukunft anfangen nicht
anständig leisten kann das ist eine der
härtesten Debatten in Deutschland die
sie führen können warum war das jeden
Menschen in diesem Land betrifft und das
einzige was sie hier gemacht haben ist
zu sagen ja Mensch es gibt einen Ringen
in der Regierung darum was die beste
Lösung ist und das finden Sie
problematisch das sind irgendwie traurig
ich hätte mir erwartet dass sie sich
hier hinstellen und sagen mensch Leute
das sind unsere Antworten so soll die
Welt aussehen sie sind doch in der
Opposition sie können doch frei von der
Leber weg sagen was ist CDU Meinung ich
hätte das erwartet hier von ihnen weil
das wäre seriöse Politik gewesen das
finde ich eigentlich ziemlich traurig
was sie gemacht haben es ist doch klar
es braucht eine Novelle des
gebäudenergiegesetzes und es ist auch
klar so wie das aus der Regierung
gekommen ist wird das nicht durch dieses
Parlament gehen es braucht eine
Novellierung hier ist der richtige Ort
wo wir das diskutieren die Ampel ist die
richtige Regierung die das diskutieren
kann weil wir die Bandbreite innerhalb
Deutschlands abbilden wir sagen ganz
klar als beides Demokraten der Weg den
auch mal ebenhofer gerade aufgezeigt das
ist doch der richtige wir setzen auf
eine starke klare CO2 Bepreisung über
den Emissionshandel den wir möglichst
vorziehen sollten und das ist auch
richtig so aber das hat natürlich
Konsequenzen weil sie einen
Emissionshandel ja nicht alleine stehen
lassen können das hätten sie vor 20
Jahren machen können aber natürlich
brauchen Sie jetzt Maßnahmen drumherum
die sie bauen damit der Preis die Leute
nicht überfordert und deswegen ja wir
werden dafür sorgen dass das ist ein
gutes Gesetz wird das wird so kommen
meine Damen und Herren das ist doch
klare Anspruch aber das heißt doch auch
dass wir jetzt darüber ringen müssen
weil es eben ein so breites so großes
Gesetz ist natürlich müssen wir dafür
sorgen dass es technologieoffen ist dass
die Leute selber entscheiden können aber
wir können doch technologieoffenheit
nicht damit verwechseln wie das gerne
hier mal getan wird zu sagen ja das
heißt die Leute müssen nichts machen
klar ist doch wir brauchen ein
Förderkonzept wir brauchen eine klare
Kopplung an die kommunale wärmeplanung
ich weiß dass der SPD sehr wichtig und
so richtig so es ist richtig so dass wir
den Leuten sagen wie sieht meine Heizung
die heizungsmöglichkeit bei mir in der
Zukunft aus und das ist doch völlig
richtig dafür zu sagen dass das so ist
und dann gibt es natürlich noch eine
Menge kleiner ordnungsrechtlicher
Details in diesem Gesetz und meiner
Meinung können die alle raus ist doch
ganz klar dass wir nicht ins
Mikromanagement gehen müssen bei den
Leuten zu Hause ist doch ganz klar dass
die Menschen sorgen dafür haben dass wir
in deren Eigentum Eingreifen natürlich
müssen wir dafür sorgen dass es ein
Gesetz ist dass die Leute mitnimmt das
Klimaschutz die Leute mitnimmt aber der
falsche Weg ist doch diese Debatte nicht
zu führen der falsche Weg ist doch das
was sie in den letzten vier Jahren vor
dieser Regierung gemacht haben den Kopf
in den Sand zu stecken und Angst davor
zu haben so eine Debatte auszuhalten es
ist richtig dass wir diese Debatte
führen und es ist auch gut so und ja
natürlich ich weiß das sorgt für
Nervosität auch in der Ampel auch bei
solchen Worten wie wortbrüchigkeit und
solchen Geschichten klar sorgt das von
der Universität verstehe ich das ist ein
hartes Gesetz das tut doch mal weh aber
wichtiger ist doch als ein schnelles
Gesetz zu machen ein gutes Gesetz zu
machen weil das ist das was die Menschen
von uns erwartet die Menschen erwarten
von uns dass wir dafür sorgen am Ende
des Tages die Antworten die wir gerade
benannt haben jetzt das umzusetzen und
klar ist doch dass so ein Gesetz jede
Menge Fragen darf aber auch wir sehen
was auf europäischer Ebene passiert und
da ich mir jetzt auch noch mal eine
Antwort von Ihnen Herr sparen erwartet
wie Sie Ursula von der Leyen davon
überzeugen wollen dass das was die
Kommission da gerade vorschlägt mit 2027
gasheizungsverbot mit dem dämmen von
Gebäuden die sich in Deutschland schon
keiner mehr leisten kann das sein dass
sie da mal macht wird spricht und sagt
nee Leute so geht das auf europäischer
Ebene nicht da hätte ich mir mal
erwartet dass da mal ein paar Antworten
kommt so ein Trauerspiel was da gerade
passiert sie stellen sich hier hin und
halten große Reden und dann haben sie
ihre Leute nicht im Griff na das sind
Trauerspiel da würde ich sagen auf
europäischer Ebene wird da mal ein paar
ein paar Hausaufgaben zu machen Liebe
Junioren
am Ende des Tages werden wir ein gutes
Gesetz beschließen das ist noch nicht so
das ist noch ein gutes Gesetz aus
unserer Sicht das heißt aber das ist das
normalste der Welt dass wir das im
parlamentarischen Verfahren machen
und ich glaube auch es tut uns gut diese
Debatte hier zu führen weil es ist ein
redeparlament und die Debatte
beschäftigt nicht nur uns hier sondern
beschäftigt auch die Menschen in
Deutschland und deswegen vielen Dank
Lukas Köhler war das am 7 juli beginnt
die Sommerpause die parlamentarische bis
dahin gibt's noch drei Sitzungswoche und
das wird knapp dieses Gesetz vorher zu
verabschieden und Kollegen Herr Dr
Köhler mit Verlaub das Trauerspiel das
ist der
Dauerstreit in der ampelregierung über
das heizungsgesetz es ist das was sie
hier aufführen seit Monaten das ist das
was zu Verunsicherung für bei den
Menschen sie stellen immer neue
Pflichten in den Raum sie beantworten
nicht die Frage wie findet der soziale
Ausgleich statt wie geht's mit dem
Förderung weiter was kommt auf die
Menschen zu und statt hier eine Antwort
zu geben statt ein Gesetz vorzulegen
über das man debattieren kann
stattdessen haben sie es gerade ihre
Fraktionen ja nach Monaten jetzt
abgesagt sie haben dafür gesorgt dass es
Parlament im nicht über ein Gesetz
diskutieren kann mir ist egal ob sie
sind oder sie sind oder ob sie sind die
Ampel insgesamt hat nichts vorgelegt und
das unterscheidet uns von ihnen wir
haben Hormone
wir haben vor Monaten
unsere Vorschläge hier vorgelegt mit
einem Antrag eingebracht für eine
wärmewende technologieoffen und
sozialverträglich mit dem Grundsatz
fördern und fördern statt verbieten und
verordnen wie es bei ihnen ist unsere
Vorschläge eingebracht wir haben dazu
Anhörungen durchgeführt wir haben es zur
Abstimmung gebracht sie haben es
abgelehnt ist ihr Recht als mehr als
Mehrheit aber warum sagen Sie Ihre
eigenen Dinge ab warum müssen wir die
Sachverständigen wieder ausladen die sie
am Freitag morgen anhören müssen das ist
ampelversagen und ich sage Ihnen wer sie
sagen es ist ein völlig das ist ein
völlig normaler ein völlig normaler
parlamentarischer Vorgang wo ist denn
der parlamentarische Vorgang der ist
hier wenn wir eine Aktuelle Stunde
beantragt haben aber sie haben doch gar
kein Gesetz das ist nicht das türkische
Gesetz das ist der offenbarungseidigkeit
Gott Erklärung der Ampel in der
Klimapolitik
und wenn wenn Matthias Hirsch für die
SPD sich über eine Kampagne beklagt dann
frage ich wer ist denn der gemeint es
ist die spd-kollegin Limbacher die
erklärt habecks heizgesetz verbreitet
Angst bei den Menschen im Saarland ist
gemeint die Ministerpräsident Rehlinger
die sagt statt diesen vielfachen
Umstellung sollte man doch besser mal
die Kommunen unterstützen wer ist denn
da gemeint ist es der Ministerpräsident
Wolke der sagt es gibt keine Antworten
auf die soziale Fragen sei so viel
ungeklärt dass man es um drei Jahre
verschieben müsste was ist der gemeint
und dann fällt mir ein Olaf Scholz war
hier bei der regierungsbefragung nach 30
Stunden koalitionsverschluss und wir
haben ihn gefragt warum steht der so
wenig drin zu dem heizungsgesetz und ich
erinnere mich gut an die Antwort die
Antwort war weil da sind wir uns total
einig mehr mussten wir nicht
reinschreiben und er sagt jetzt und er
sagt jetzt es braucht noch ein paar
kosmetische Korrekturen man fragt sich
in welcher Welt lebt dieser
Bundeskanzler er hat die eigenen
Forderungen die eigenen Forderungen aus
seiner eigenen Fraktion nicht dir
grundsätzliche Dinge in diesem Gesetz in
Frage stellen nicht kosmetische
Korrektur grundsätzliche Fragen werden
dort gestellt deshalb ist schon die
Erwartungen an den Bundeskanzler er hat
sich plaketieren lassen als klimakanzler
hier geht es um eine wichtige
klimapolitische Weichenstellung wo ist
dieser klimakanze wir haben hier im
Parlament in der Bundesregierung nicht
gesehen seit gestern Abend angetreten
ist seine Aufgabe hier mit Koordinierung
und Führung zu einem Ergebnis zu kommen
weil wir Klarheit brauchen weil die
Menschen Klarheit brauchen und ich will
ihnen sagen was unsere Linie dabei ist
ich will Ihnen auch sagen dass wir
beschlossen haben wir haben übrigens von
1990 bis
2021/45% CO2 bei den Gebäuden eingespart
und wer mit dem Klima Paket 2019 gesagt
wir müssen es beschleunigen und wir
haben und wir haben vorangebracht wir
haben mit dem Klima Paket gesagt man
muss beschleunigen wir haben im
Vermittlungsausschuss dafür eingestellt
wir haben die co2-bepreisung eingeführt
moderate Einstieg und Schritt für
Schritt aufwuchs und Matthias nur
schweres gemeinsam beschlossen man kann
nachlesen wie steigt die Ampel hat sie
im letzten Jahr ausgesetzt aber das ist
der schrittweise aus aufwuchs und das
ist der Gegenteil zwischen dem was mit
diesen mit diesem Weg den wir
vorgeschlagen kommt dass die uns von der
Ampel unterscheidet hier weiß man genau
moderate Einstieg es wird Jahr für Jahr
teurer die Botschaft war eben nicht es
kann alles so bleiben wie es ist sondern
die Botschaft die Botschaft ist die
fossilen werden Schritt für Schritt
teurer aber jeder kann sich darauf
einstellen werden in einer Förderung
verbunden wer in eine neue Heizung
investiert und sich für eine öko-heizung
entscheidet der bekommt eine Förderung
was hat die Ampel bisher gemacht die
Förderung die kürzt bei uns gab es
50%, 50 % für die Wärmepumpe 40 %. es
gibt es soll jetzt nach habe und geiles
30% geben dass er eine neue kürzen statt
eine zusätzliche Förderung damit man
damit schafft man für sichern und weil
die Grünen so rufen schauen Sie mal was
der Ministerpräsident Kretschmann
gestern gesagt hat der sagte man kann
von den Menschen nichts verlangen was
sie nicht machen können ein wahrer Satz
und der wirft ein schlaglich darauf dass
dieses Gesetz eben nicht
technologieoffen ist sie schreiben
alle Optionen ein wärmeetze Heizen mit
Holz Biomethan Wasserstoff Herr Kollege
komme ich zu dem Schluss dass das was
Ministerpräsident Kretschmann einfach in
diesem Gesetz nicht drin steht
nächste Rednerin ist für die
SPD-Fraktion Verena Hubert
[Applaus]
Herr Merzig können auch gerne reden
haben sie ja nicht von daher fange ich
dann jetzt mal an sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen gestern haben wir ein Jubiläum
gefeiert 160 Jahre SPD viele große
Politikerinnen und Politiker viele
historische Errungenschaften einer der
prägenden Persönlichkeiten unserer
Partei war kurt-schumacher und der hat
einmal was sehr schlaues gesagt das
Wesen der Opposition ist der permanente
Versuch an konkreten Tatbeständen mit
konkreten Vorschlägen der Regierung den
positiven Gestaltungswillen der
Opposition aufzuzwingen
das war seine Antwort
im September
1949 auf die erste Regierungserklärung
von Konrad Adenauer was man so früh
verstanden hat daran sollten Sie sich
mal ein Beispiel nehmen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der
Opposition wo ist
verwaltungswille und wo sind denn bitte
Ihre Ideen ich kenne keine hier in
diesem Haus
konstruktiver Vorschläge
wie Öl ins Feuer sie machen hier
irgendwelche perfiden
unterschriftskampagnen so geht keine
konstruktive Mitarbeit
enden
[Applaus]
keine Option nichts zu tun nicht zu
handeln eine aktuelle Studie sagt 900
Milliarden Euro sind die Kosten wenn wir
jetzt nicht beim Klimawandel Handeln
allein in Deutschland allein über die
nächsten Jahrzehnte wir verspielen
Vielfalt wir verstehen wirtschaftlichen
stark starke wirtschaftliche Leistung
und vor allen Dingen haben wir das
Problem von Hitze Starkregen und anderen
Ereignissen also wir müssen handeln wir
wollen zwei und 2045 klimaneutral sein
und deswegen haben wir jetzt keine Zeit
mehr für Verweigerung und es ist Zeit
für große Lösungen und das überfordert
sie anscheinend
und ja es stimmt der Weg der ist
ruckelig in die Transformation und
deswegen bauen wir auch ein Gerüst damit
einer runterfällt und das ist das
Gebäude Energiegesetz und uns als SPD
sind in diesem Verfahren drei Punkte
ganz wichtig erstens
Finanzierbarkeit wir wollen dass niemand
überfordert wird zweitens
wir wollen wir sind eine Mieterinnen und
mieternationen wir wollen die
Mieterinnen und Mieter in diesem Land
schützen und ja liebe linke da können
sie uns dann auch dran messen dass wir
die Modernisierungsumlage nicht einfach
nur überwälzen und die Menschen aus
ihren Wohnungen raus sanieren das wird
nicht passieren
und ein dritter Punkt da bin ich dem
Kollegen Köhler dankbar sie du hast auf
die kommunale wärmeplanung wir sind ja
jetzt hier unter uns mit ein paar Gästen
und auch im Hohen Hause darauf
hingewiesen dass wir eine kommunale
wärmeplanung als zweites Gesetz in petto
haben aber was bedeutet das denn das
eine ist die individuelle Lösung und wir
wollen ja gar nicht dass ich jetzt
wieder eine Wärmepumpe Kauf baut und
macht sondern wir sagen es muss ja eben
auch eine staatliche Daseinsvorsorge
geben indem wir die Abwärme nutzen indem
wir die Fernwärme nutzen indem wir
Quartiere vernetzen Biogas und all das
was ist jetzt braucht in dieser
historischen Transformation damit uns
eben diese wärmewende gelegt und jetzt
kann man ja bei Kampagnen der Union
immer schöne neue Worte auch lernen ich
habe jetzt gelesen das ist jetzt habex
neuer heizhammer also ich finde
eigentlich ganz gut die kommunale
wärmeplanungen außerdem ist auch da
Clara geibels mit dran beteiligt aber
mein Gott was soll's in diesen Zeiten
lieber Kampagne lieber Worte wir
arbeiten an Lösungen für dieses Land
dazu sind Sie herzlich eingeladen
und es ist schon ein bisschen
verwunderlich Liebe Union dass sie jetzt
viel von sozialer Kälte sprechen ich
sage Ihnen mal was soziale Kälte ist
nichts Tunes soziale Kälte denn dann
kommt der CO2-Preis dann werden sich die
Leute das irgendwann nicht mehr leisten
können und Sie haben doch vor 22 Jahren
mit beschlossen dass ihr Heizungen Klima
neutral das Heizungen in 22 Jahren
klimaneutral sein müssen und sie kennen
auch die Prognosen was das alles
bedeutet und deswegen sage ich hören Sie
doch mal bitte auf die Bevölkerung zu
verunsichern sondern machen sie doch
jetzt einfach mal mit wenn
so ein Gesetz verabschieden wann das
dann und wie das dann mit welchen
Fristen in Kraft tritt das machen wir
hier gemeinsam im parlamentarischen
Verfahren und da sind wir auch schon
dran in guten Gesprächen in guten
Verhandlungen und die Menschen in diesem
Land können sich auf diese Regierung auf
diese Ampel Koalition verlassen
herzlichen Dank
Verena Huberts war das für die
SPD-Fraktion und möchte hier natürlich
darauf dringend dass auch die Regierung
Verlass sei auch wenn es dort immer
wieder zu Streitigkeiten kommt in einer
Koalition auch nicht ungewöhnlich
Bernhard Hermann spricht nun für Bündnis
90 die Grünen er sitzt unter anderem im
Ausschuss für Klimaschutz und Energie
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ja sie
verunsichern und sie trauen sich einst
den Menschen nicht zu sagen die einfache
mathematische Aufgabe
2045 bis
2024 sind 21 Jahre sagen sie die
Menschen jede Gasheizung wird nicht
älter als 21 Jahre oder sie lügen
bezüglich des Klimaschutz seit 2045
seien Sie so ehrlich
liebe Kolleginnen der Union die Sie
diese aktuelle Stunde verlangt haben
dass es Dir gutes Recht abgesehen davon
dass sie selbst lange Regierungszeit
gehabt hätten die wärmewende auf den Weg
zu bringen konnte es ihnen erst gar
nicht schnell genug gehen jetzt wollen
sie wieder ganz von vorne anfangen
morgen bedanken sie wahrscheinlich
wieder es würde alles zu lange dauern
verunsichert ebenso wie ihre neuesten
unsäglichen Stasi Vergleiche in dieser
Sache aber das beabsichtigen Sie
vielleicht Verunsicherung sollte es
Ihnen entgangen sein wir führen parallel
berichterstattergespräche wir verhandeln
das Energieeffizienzgesetz wir bereiten
die kommunale wärmeplanung Vorhand wir
bereiten nicht zuletzt das
Klimaschutzgesetz vor glauben Sie mir
das tun wir nicht erst seitdem sie immer
und immer wieder mit Anträgen und
aktuellen Stunden zum heizungsgesetz
kommen Sie Herr Spahn haben wir eine
Debatte letztens vorgeworfen ich würde
den Klimaschutz zur Glaubensfrage machen
statt vernünftig diese anzugehen und
mich gegen den bösen Rest der Welt
einigeln ich weiß nicht wie sie sich das
mit dem einigeln vorstellen
aber ich für meinen Teil und ich weiß
dass es meinen Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ähnlich geht werde jeden Tag von
BürgerInnen
von Unternehmen von Verbänden von
Stadtwerken mit den Fragen zu wärmende
konfrontiert und das sage ich Ihnen mit
aller Klarheit deutlich deutlich
konstruktiver als Sie das hier tun
daher stelle ich mich diesen sehr gern
ja ich hätte mir auch gewünscht dass das
Gebäude Energiegesetz dieses Haus schon
längst passiert hätte und wir in diesem
Sinne echte Planungssicherheit
geschaffen hätten
danach vor allem werde ich nämlich immer
wieder gefragt Klarheit das interessiert
vor allem wie es dazu steht dass ehrlich
zu sagen da gerade nur auf den immer
noch laufenden Prozess verweisen zu
müssen ist natürlich ernüchternd
umso wichtiger ist es daher
konstruktives herangehen statt
geschürter Verunsicherung
Verlässlichkeit statt Nichteinhaltung
getroffener Vereinbarungen das muss uns
jetzt hier im Haus alle leiten
derweil machen wir Grünen was
Parlamentarier tun sollten die Anmerkung
der BürgerInnen Verbände und daneben
aufzunehmen ernst zu nehmen und in die
Verbesserung der Gesetzgebung einfließen
lassen ich habe aber noch mal einen
Blick in ihre Forderung geworfen
sie wollten fordern und fördern beides
aber nicht konsequent da ist kein Mut
man könnte auch sagen nicht die
Ehrlichkeit nicht das Rückgrat kenne ich
aus Sachsen von ihrer CDU den
BürgerInnen zuzutrauen die
Herausforderung auch meistern zu können
und ihre Wohnung tatsächlich nachhaltig
auszurüsten
aber wo wir bei Glaubensfragen waren sie
kennen wahrscheinlich als Union als
christlich demokratische Union das
biblische Gleichnis von den Talenten ein
kleiner Tipp das Silber zu vergraben und
aus Angst etwas falsch zu machen nichts
damit anzufangen nie eine hilfreiche
Option
fördern um zu befähigen Menschen in
ihrem Willen ernst zu nehmen die er zur
Veränderung beitragen wollen das sagen
die alle im Unterschied zu ihnen die sie
verunsichern wollen auch etwas zu
fordern das ist ein für alle in manchen
pathologischer Umgang und das stärkt
auch und nimmt den Bürgerwillen Ernst
die wissen das was zu tun ist damit
wären wir bei einer zweiten zentralen
Forderung der Planungssicherheit denn
die hatten wir muss man zugeben unter
ihre Regierung in gewisser Weise
durchaus leider aber meist nur unter dem
Motto wer nichts macht macht auch nichts
verkehrt und das in einer sich
verändernden Welt das kann nicht gut
gehen oder nur bis die Folgen der
Klimakatastrophe
stichwortetal Elbe Hochwasser Baum
sterben mal wieder mit voller Wucht
zuschlagen oder Autokraten von denen sie
uns unabhängig und von denen sie uns
abhängig gemacht haben auf die Idee
kommen Kriege anzuzetteln oder aus
welchen Gründen auch immer Lieferung
fossiler Rohstoffe einstellen machen wir
uns und die Menschen hier doch nichts
vor heizen mit fossilen könnte binnen
kurzer Zeit wieder absurd und für viele
nicht leistbar teuer werden
das müssen wir unbedingt verhindern
indem wir konzentriert geordnet und für
alle leistbar auf erneuerbares heizen
umstellen die wärmewende ist ebenso eine
soziale Frage wie eine des Klimaschutzes
wir haben so viel gutes Potenzial
Industrie der Innovationskraft der
Ingenieure der Handwerkerschaft und auch
wenn es um gerade erwähnten biblischen
Gleichnis um verwalten ging was auch
eher der Ansatz ihrer Regierungsperioden
war dann geht es uns doch ums gestalten
denn das ist jetzt nötig die Wählerinnen
und Wähler erwarten Gestaltung von uns
und ja auch von ihnen falls Sie noch als
konstruktiver Opposition überhaupt
auftreten wollen
definieren Sie doch mal was sie mit
technologieoffenheit in ihrem Sinne
meinen reden wir darüber was meinen Sie
damit und mein letzter Punkt im Sinne
auch ihrer wähler:innen vielleicht
finden Sie ja auch eines Tages zu
konstruktiven Vorgehen als Opposition so
Handwerker vor Ort mehr und mehr ist tun
ich bin gespannt vielen Dank
Bernhard Herrmann war das hier in diese
Aktuellen Stunde der nächste Redner
spricht für die FDP-Fraktion Christoph
Meier ist der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzender
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren uns eint in dieser
Koalition das Ziel Klimaneutralität 2045
wir werden diesen Weg in allen
relevanten Bereichen zusammen gehen und
gestalten und das trifft auch auf die
wärmewende zu oder nennen sie es
heizungswände die Reduzierung des
co2-bedarfs im Gebäude bestand und bei
allen Aufgeregtheiten die wir in den
letzten Wochen hatten glaube ich dazu
gehört dann auch das ein oder andere
was Wortbruch angeht und andere
Formulierung da sollten wir uns alle ein
wenig beruhigen wir werden hier im
Parlament ein gutes Gesetz zusammen
diskutieren und beschließen und wenn die
Debatte hier von der Union geführt wird
und wieder darüber reden dass wir hier
mit unterschiedlichen Positionen im
Parlament dieses Gesetz verbessern
werden
und denn hier die Aufregung kommt denn
frage ich mich doch welche
selbstverzwergung haben sie als
Parlamentarier in den letzten Jahren
eigentlich durch litten wir sind das
Parlament wir sind die erste Kraft im
Staat und wir werden entsprechende
Korrekturen vornehmen wir werden ein
Kompromiss finden meine Damen und Herren
und zu den Prämissen der Kollege Köhler
hat schon einiges gesagt der
Rechnungshof hat vor drei Jahren
formuliert dass die Umsetzung der
Energiewende in Deutschland der teuerste
und ineffizienteste Weg ist den man hier
bestreiten kann und das darf uns bei
diesem Gesetz nicht noch einmal
passieren und wenn der Rechnungshof das
vor drei Jahren feststellt dann ist das
auch genau das Armutszeugnis für
Kollegen wie Sie Herr Jung die das
maßgeblich mitgestaltet haben der
Rechnungshof hat gesagt dass in den
letzten 16 Jahren sie den Weg der
Energiewende falsch beschrieben haben
und wir werden diesen Fehler hier nicht
noch mal machen beim Gebäude Energie
gesetzt Klimaneutralität
Bedarf breite Akzeptanz und dann muss
man die Problemlagen auch offen
diskutieren und das tun wird
die wärmewende muss wirtschaftlich
umsetzbar sein und zwar für den
Einzelnen das haben wir schon gehört
aber auch für den Staat insgesamt
und es muss klar sein sage ich als
Haushälter dass der Staat nicht alle
Kosten übernehmen kann die Anforderungen
an dem Gesetz oder andersgesetz sind
auch daran zu messen wir haben
vereinbart
dass die Finanzierung über den KTF läuft
und wir müssen uns und deswegen ist es
wichtig dass wir die fördersystematik
parallel zur Beratung dieses Gesetzes
hinbekommen darüber im Klaren sein dass
mehr Geld nicht da sein wird und wir
können es uns an diesem zentralen Thema
nicht erlauben dass nach einem halben
Jahr gegebenenfalls der KTF leer ist und
dann heißt wir müssen irgendwo anders
mehr Geld herbekommen was wir nicht
schaffen deswegen gilt auch hier
Gründlichkeit vor Schnelligkeit
und wir sollten auch nicht in Versuch
nehmen einzelne Gruppen in der
Bevölkerung hier mit einer Art
Sonderopfer heranzuziehen Stichwort
Vermieter die Klimapolitik und die
Anforderungen betreffen alle Gruppen in
der Gesellschaft und deswegen müssen
auch alle Gruppen meinen Beitrag leisten
wir können nicht einzelne Gruppen
gegeneinander ausspielen Härtefälle
müssen natürlich entsprechend geschützt
werden aber wir können nicht die Debatte
führen guter guter Mieter böser
Vermieter gleiche Regel für alle
und das gilt auch für öffentliche
Gebäude es darf keine Privilegierung
durch Staates oder von Krankenhäusern
nur sozialen Einrichtungen gehen
gegenüber den Menschen und wir müssen
das GEG zusammendenken mit der
kommunalen wärmeplanung auch das haben
wir schon gehört und wenn man diese
Punkte zusammenzieht denn wird sehr
deutlich dass wir andere Vorstellungen
haben wie wir zum Thema oder wie wir zum
Ziel der Klimaneutralität kommen uns
eint das Ziel aber mit den Weg streiten
wir und dies werden wir jetzt in aller
Ruhe mit der notwendigen Zeit wir
brauchen zusammenführen und am Ende
werden wir dann ein gutes Gesetz haben
meine Damen und Herren
ich hatte gehofft dass der jung
zumindest was Substanzielles sagt nach
Herrn Spahn aber am Ende war es genau so
wie die letzten 16 Jahre unionsgeführte
Bundesregierung wieder kein Inhalt
wieder nichts auf das man sich in einer
Debatte einlassen kann und deswegen ist
es so ein bisschen so wie bei all den
anderen Themen die sie ja auch
aufgeführt haben mehr sparen und
teilweise auch der jung sie schlagen
sich in die Bücher sie wollen die
Verantwortung für die Fehler in der
Gesellschaft hier in Deutschland in den
letzten Jahren die sie in der
Bundesregierung maßgeblich mitgestaltet
haben nicht übernehmen dass sie
legitimes Recht als Opposition aber ist
das legitime Recht von uns dass wir
darauf nicht eingehen wir werden ein
gutes Gesetz machen und dieses Gesetz
wird am Ende die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
dieses Landes weiterbringen ich freue
mich auf die parlamentarische Beratung
die sicherlich bald beginnen werden
herzlichen Dank
Christoph Meyer war das wir haben noch
zwei Redner in dieser aktuellen Stunde
jetzt spricht Michael Kießling für die
cdu/csu er sitzt unter anderem im
Ausschuss für Wohnen statt Entwicklung
bauen und Kommunen sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren sehr geehrter Hartmann sehr
geehrter Frau Huberts die einzigen die
Verunsicherung beitragen sind sie mit
ihrem rum mit diesem Gesetz meine Damen
und Herren
sie sprechen heute dass dieses Gesetz
beraten werden soll im Parlament warum
bringen sie es nicht ein warum wurde es
diese Woche nicht aufgesetzt
ist es so gut ist es so schlecht haben
sie mit dem oppositionspartner in der
Koalition gesprochen mit der FDP warum
kommen Sie nicht zum Punkt meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren
sie verunsichert die Eigentümer sie
wollen sich Dieter sie fühlen sich auch
die Wirtschaft die Bauwirtschaft sie
haben Gesetz wo sie fordern wo sie
Anforderungen stellen wo Strafen
festgelegt sind sie haben aber keine
Antwort darauf wie das Ganze finanziert
werden soll das Ganze gefördert werden
soll und da reden sie von sozialer ja
Ausgeglichenheit das im soziale
berücksichtigen das kommt in diesem
Gesetz viel zu kurz
dieses Lippenbekenntnis
von Herrn Finanzminister dem Gesetz erst
zuzustimmen Kabinett zu sagen ist
Parlament soll es richten ja dann
bringen sie doch Parlament dass man es
richten kann warum kommt es nicht wenn
man die Kritik hört Frau Robert sie
haben gesagt wir haben keine Vorschläge
gebracht haben Sie unsere Vorschläge
nicht gegeben haben Sie einen Antrag
nicht gelesen haben sie das Habeck
Syndrom gehen Sie nicht auf die Kritik
ein hören Sie keine Kritik hören Sie
keine Vorschläge meine Damen und Herren
das ist doch der Punkt wir sind bei den
Menschen wir wissen was fortgesprochen
werden sie wollen Gasheizungen verbieten
Habeck baut Gaskraftwerke
meine sehr geehrten sie verbieten
Holzheizungen waren sie schon mal im
ländlichen Raum wo jeder seinen Wald hat
wo jeder das Holz nutzen will das
Abfallholz nutzen will warum soll das
nicht thermisch verwertet werden sie
doch nachwachsende Rohstoffe da sage ich
liebe Ampel sie springen viel zu kurz
die Kritik klickt die FDP sagt sie auch
technologieoffenheit wo ist denn die
Technologie sie reden von Wärmepumpen
sie reden nicht von nachwachsenden
Rohstoffwert gesagt Holz fließen sie aus
denken wir an die Wärmepumpe wenn sie an
Wärmepumpe denken müssen sie auch
erneuerbare Energien denken
wenn es ja wenn sie Wärmepumpen haben
müssten sie eigentlich die
photovoltaikpflicht auf den Deckel auch
herbeiführen weil ohne Wärmepumpe ohne
Photovoltaik sie brauchen Strom 50% der
Stroms ist Fossil momentan
das heißt auch die Wärmepumpe wird in
Zukunft teurer wenn der fossile Anteil
entsprechend
sie setzen nicht auf
technologieoffenheit besseren sie das
Gesetz nach und bringen sie es endlich
auch mal ein
zweitens unser Ansatz ist fördern und
fördern das haben wir in der letzten
Regierung mit der SPD auf den Weg
gebracht was machen sie
sie sagen sie fördern aber fördern nicht
sie verordnen sie verbieten im Gesetz
stehen die Strafen fest wie es
unterstützt werden sollen das umgesetzt
werden soll berücksichtigen gar nicht
sie müssen auch gemeinsam denken sie
müssen sie wärmeerzeugen und Denken im
Gebäude und die Wärme Dämmung auch das
kommt zu kurz wer soll sich denn das
leisten und da reden Sie dass wir die
Menschen unsicher die Menschen können
rechnen draußen wenn sie sagen wo die
Heizung tauschen und ich muss mein
Gebäude noch dämmen dass die neue
Heizung funktioniert dann kann das jeder
draußen nachvollziehen was das
letztendlich kostet die Ampel macht die
Menschen haben meine Damen und Herren
und drittens Planbarkeit machen sie
realistische Fristen machen sie
Anforderungen die auch erfüllbar sind
wenn ich lese kaufe 55 Standard für den
Bestand haben Sie schon mal den
baukulturbericht gelesen da steht drin K
für 85 wer soll sich denn das leisten
sollen wir den Altbestand abreißen neu
bauen wo sind wir dann beim CO2 meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren ja Herr
Hartmann sie müssen doch wissen die
meisten die meisten Gebäude sind im
Bestand die saniert werden müssen und
sie wissen auch dass die Heizungen dort
getauscht werden müssen Sie wissen auch
dass wir hohen Sanierungsbedarf haben
bei 16 Millionen Einfamilien heißen 9
Familien 9 Millionen Häuser sind vor der
ersten Energieverordnung gebaut worden
da wissen wir dass es nicht einfach ist
eine Wärmepumpe einzubauen das kostet
Geld meine sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
letztendlich sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren
dieses Gesetz ist Murks machen sie es
neu bringen sie erst neues Gesetz dann
können wir darüber reden herzlichen Dank
Michael Kiesling fordert hier ein
komplett in neues Gesetz aus dem Hause
von Bundeswirtschaftsminister Robert
Habeck nun werden wir aber erst einmal
zur letzten Rednerin in dieser aktuellen
Stunde kommen das ist Nina Scheer die
Sprecherin für Klimaschutz und Energie
der SPD-Fraktion
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ich wäre aus den Reihen der CSU etwas
vorsichtig von 50% Anteil fossiler
Energie im Stromsektor zu sprechen weil
wir müssen uns natürlich dann schnell
fragen warum sind wir bei noch 50%
gegenüber den 50% Erneuerbaren diese 50%
fossile Anteile liegen insbesondere an
der Verhinderungspolitik die mit
Schwerpunkt in Bayern zu verordnen ist
Schwerpunkt in Bayern
Abstandsregelung und dergleichen sie
wissen dass das der das Element der
Verhinderungspolitik der letzten Jahre
ist und leider haben sie das natürlich
auch weiterhin nicht aufgelöst auch wenn
Sie das manchmal glauben machen wollen
wir haben mit unserem Programm zur
wärmeplanung wir haben es ja heute
gehört es ist
greifbar dass wir es auch dann
parlamentarisch beraten und es wird auch
die parlamentarische Barsche natürlich
dann zügig durchzuführen sein das ist
uns allen klar weil wir schnell
Rechtssicherheit Klarheit brauchen die
Menschen sind maximal verunsichert durch
solche Aktionen wie die ihre heute
wieder und deswegen müssen wir natürlich
und das uns allen dran gelegt schnell
ein Gesetz bekommen was klar aufzeigt
wie der Pfad der Wärme Planung sein wird
der wärmewende sein wird und natürlich
dabei die Verzahnung der kommunalen
wärmeplanung mit dem Blick behalten
deswegen ist es uns auch wichtig aus der
SPD-Fraktion dass das Miteinander
gedacht wird dass der Mieterschutz
enthalten ist es wurde schon einfach
meiner Frau Kollegin Verena Hubert dass
wir natürlich darauf achten werden dass
in der Systematik das Gesetzes die
Steigerungen die Kostensteigerungen
abgefangen werden dass sie nicht bei dem
Mieterinnen und Mieter landen und das
ist natürlich eine ein Element geben
wird dass die Förderungen die wir
implementieren dass die auch genutzt
werden weil das ist leider heute auch
schon so dass viele Förderungen
ungenutzt sind wir müssen auch da den
nordischen Knoten durchschlagen dass die
Förderungen die wir auf den Weg bringen
dass die wirklich auch genutzt werden
wir brauchen ein ermöglichungsgesetz
darum muss es gehen
und in dieser Konsequenz muss es
natürlich auch um eine bessere soziale
Staffelung gehen wird es gibt viele
Menschen in unserem Land die in der
Situation sind dass sie nicht gefördert
werden müssen in den Maßnahmen und es
gibt aber sehr viele die dringend
Forderungen brauchen wenn wir die
wärmewende umsetzen wollen deswegen ist
diese Staffelung wichtig und in der Tat
ist es auch wichtig das ist auch schon
erwähnt worden dass wir schauen diese
ganze Ermöglichung muss ja auch eine
wirtschaftlich ein technologische
Komponente haben die Menschen die daran
arbeiten die brauchen auch
Rechtssicherheit wir brauchen die
Firmenansiedlung wir brauchen die
Fachkräfte das alles braucht das Signal
des Gesetzgebers deswegen ist es uns
wichtig dass das schnell kommt und dass
wir schnell mit technologieoffenheit
wird allen erneuerbaren Energien die wir
brauchen diese Regelungen bekommen aber
ich möchte jetzt noch mal zurückkommen
auf das was hier an Anschuldigungen auch
im Raum stand weil ich bin auch der
Meinung dass es nicht besonders
verantwortlich ist wenn in diesem Zeiten
in denen es wirklich spitz auf Knopf
darum steht ob wir noch die
Klimaschutzziele erreichen können und
der Rahmenbereich ein ganz großer
Bereich da ist wenn wir ständig der
Eindruck erweckt wird dass das alles
nicht funktioniert das hier verhindert
würde dabei liegt es mit an ihnen
maßgeblich an Ihnen dass wir noch nicht
weiter sind weil über viele Jahre immer
wieder blockiert wurde
und es ist ja so dass das was von ihren
aus ihren Reihen an Vorschlägen kommt
letztendlich substanziell nur auf eine
Maßnahme wirklich verlässliche Maßnahmen
erkennbare Maßnahme konzentriert werden
kann das ist nämlich dass sie wirklich
das über den Zeit CO2-Preis regeln
wollen das ist wird immer wieder
deutlich sie sagen zwar auch erneuerbare
ja aber richtig konkret wird es doch
einmal beim CO2-Preis da kämpfen sie
wirklich für und da möchte ich sie noch
mal fragen in das in Kombination mit dem
Klimaschutzgesetz was sie ja auch jetzt
inzwischen stolz
demonstrieren ja gemeinsam verabschieden
das in Kombination wir diese Ziele die
dort verankert sind wenn sie das über
den CO2-Preis allein erreichen wollen
dann ist das verbunden mit der
Verunmöglichung von heizen in
Deutschland eine Verunmöglichung das
heißt sie machen ein Programm das
frierens in Deutschland das muss
[Applaus]
man das selbst in der größten Krise die
wir hatten lange Jahre in dem letzten
Jahr wo wir 300 Milliarden Euro in
Deutschland verabschiedet haben hier zur
Verfügung stelle um diese Überforderung
der Menschen abzuwenden das war eine
einmalige Aktion da waren wir alle
beisammen auch trotz
Meinungsverschiedenheiten auch in der
Ampel gibt das gehört Koalition dazu
aber da waren wir ganz geschlossen diese
300 Milliarden brauchen wir wer stimmt
dagegen sie haben dagegen gestimmt das
gibt dir einen Vorgeschmack das gibt ein
Vorgeschmack darauf wie sie die soziale
Abfederung dann ausgestalten würden beim
CO2-Preis ich denke er wird sehr gering
ausfallen ich bleibe dabei ein Programm
des Friedens das ist das was die Union
verfolgt nicht mit uns
das war hier die aktuelle Stunde wir
werden natürlich verfolgen wie sich die
Koalitionsparteien weiter darüber
austauschen wie es mit dem
heizungsgesetz voran gehen soll der Plan
ist ja von 20 24 an das möglichst jede
neu eingeweiberte Heizung zu 65% mit
öko-Energie betrieben wird daran gibt es
viel Kritik nicht nur aus der eigenen
Koalition sozusagen das haben wir hier
deutlich mitbekommen also wir werden
weiter schauen ob es denn noch zu einem
Gesetz vor der Sommerpause kommt wie von
SPD und Grüne gew